The psychological significance of the
biblical stories they've been sold out and
a crazy thing,
the question and answer period at
the end has been so sophisticated,
really in depth questions and the
audience is really tuned in and very,
very mature and there's so much respect
and silence during the entire lecture.
I'm sure you're very pleased,
but it's amazing.
Yeah,
I'm really pleased about it and
I've learned a tremendous amount.
I mean,
part of the reason I wanted to do a series
on the psychological significance of
the biblical stories for a long time,
15 years probably,
and never had the opportunity.
You never set itself up properly.
And I've,
I've learned a ridiculous about doing
it then I'm really looking forward to
starting it up again.
I'm going to try to do it to
go through exodus next year.
Um,
I really liked [inaudible] stories
and I know the better than I did the
Abrahamic stories,
for example,
if I had to do a lot of learning,
but that's okay.
It's often,
it's a funny thing when you're lecturing.
Sometimes it's,
I mean,
you need to have a fairly
wide background of knowledge.
Say that you can draw from,
but in,
in,
in a more specific way.
Sometimes it's not bad to be just one
step ahead of the audience and be learning
along with them because it
keeps the material really fresh.
So yeah,
that's been,
that's been an amazing thing.
I don't know how many people have
watched those biblical lectures now,
but I think it's something
upwards of 5 million.
Yeah,
that's remarkable.
And you know,
what's even more remarkable to me is when
I attend is the number of young people
in the audience.
And you know,
that's been really encouraging because
I think statistically if we look at
across the board,
I know that young people show not a
very strong interest in religion or
religious stories,
but they certainly don't attend church.
And that's true for young men.
And I know it's really funny because I'm
talking to young men about religion and
responsibility and there
there's a huge market for it,
which is
amazing.
Excuse me.
It's just amazing.
Unpredictable,
right?
A part of me is not surprised
because as you know,
I've spent the last 22 years kind of in
various types of social services from
child protection to young offenders.
And the one thing I noticed is that
people were like starving for some type of
structure and morality
and some type of um,
sort of,
you know,
way to live their lives
in a very meaningful way.
And that hunger was very apparent to me.
I didn't realize it was that strong until
actually you came along and I saw the
response to worldwide has been phenomenal.
It was something,
I was talking to the,
I call them the penguin people
because that's actually quite funny.
But I was talking to the penguin people
today and David asked me how I can
account for what's happened
over the last year,
say,
and I,
my sense essentially is that young people
haven't been talked intelligently to
about responsibility and tradition since
like 1965 and that's three generations.
It's way too long.
And so they are starving for it
because we've missed half the story.
You know,
people,
they've been fed a diet
of nothing but sugar,
freedom and impulsive pleasure and,
and uh,
and cynicism about,
about structure and tradition.
And you just can't live like that because
freedom and novelty and the unexpected
is half the story.
But structure and predictability
and responsibilities,
the other half.
And you,
you have to have both,
both halves of the story told no,
your detractors are saying that 90% of
your audience is male and most of them
are white male.
I really don't understand why
that's an issue or a private room.
So don't think it's true.
It's funny.
Um,
you know,
I was going through my Twitter
followers yesterday because I,
I'm sending some of the books and I used
a program that helped me identify the
most,
sort of a combination of
my most influential Twitter
followers and also those
who are most likely to be
engaged with my material.
And so I identified about
200 of them and you know,
there was some pretty
right wing types in there.
Three or four of them,
pretty right wing.
Um,
but you know,
three of them were a
transsexual porn stars.
Really,
really interesting because you know,
if you looked at the three
kind of radical right wingers,
you'd say,
well,
Dr. Peterson attracts radical
right wing and followers.
But then,
well,
okay,
what you're going to say about
the transsexual porn stars,
literally there were
three of them thought,
well,
what do I,
what am I like tarred with the,
with the association
transsexual Porn Stars?
Because that seems to be
just as as big a group.
So it's just,
I think Serina part of what it is is
that if you stand up against the radical
left,
let's say,
then it isn't obvious where
you're positioned on the
political spectrum because
everybody to the right of the radical
left is going to agree with you.
And that'll include people on the radical,
right?
Correct.
And then people say,
Oh,
well look,
you've got people on the radical right.
Supporting you.
You must be radical.
Right?
And it's a reasonable question,
but,
but it's generally not
posed in a reasonable way.
And you know,
you obviously you were
at the free speech rally.
I mean the,
there was no evidence whatsoever that
the crowd we attracted was anything other
than pretty damn stable
center of the road.
Citizens.